[Musique]
bonjour ça va dit vous avez vu casimir
mais leur d'avoir des problèmes
aujourd'hui
venez avec moi je vais essayer de savoir
ce qui se passe suivez-moi kazimi
casimir bonjour dis donc tu m'as l'air
bien ce monsieur est ce que je peux
aider je veux bien oui je cherche ce que
vous dire exactement
l'imagination c'est simple il suffit de
regarder dans le dictionnaire
l'imagination c'est la faculté ou la
possibilité que possèdent l'esprit
d'évoquer des images voilà casimir
ah bon bah je ne suis pas plus avancé
toutes ces sommes pourtant tiens on
prend un exemple tu connais la chanson
de l'île aux enfants
oui oui voici venu le temps des rires et
des chants à toi casimir souviens toi du
couple est ce jardin n'est pas loin car
il suffit d'un peu d'imagination pour
que tout près de vous pousse ses fleurs
ses rires et ses chansons ça veut dire
qu'avec un peu d'imagination toit et les
amis qui sont chez eux
vous pouvez vous croire en train de
jouer dans le jardin de l'île aux
enfants
tu me l'as compris ça ouais mais c'est
idiot mais tais toi tais toi c'est le
producteur de l'émission qui a écrit les
paroles
non mais tu n'as rien compris quand je
dis cet idiot ça veut dire que l'exemple
que tu as choisie est idiot je ne peux
pas imaginer que je suis mariée aux
enfants puisque ogilvy c'est vrai que tu
as raison le cet exemple est très très
mal choisi pour toi mais tu sais casimir
pourquoi ne serais tu pas toi même
d'imaginer quelque chose tu sais quand
on imagine quelque chose très fort et
bien il peut arriver qu'on voit des
choses extraordinaires
allez je te laisse casimir fusionnerait
pour voir françois bon
imaginons qu est ce que je pourrais bien
imaginer à bas par exemple qu'il y a un
gros orage dans l'île aux enfants
[Applaudissements]
oh non non non non non non non je ne
veux pas imaginer ça j'ai trop peur du
tonnerre non imaginons autre chose mais
qui par exemple qu'il va neiger un rouge
et trois aux nombreux moments dont on
l'a la wii avec ce vent c'est pas
possible j'ai vraiment trop froid
non imaginons quelque chose d'un de plus
agréable
je ne sais pas par exemple imaginons
qu'il y a des fleurs et des feux et sur
l'arbre rouge
attention j'imagine
oh oh que c'est beau
oh la la l'imagination est vraiment une
chose formidable
bon je vais également imaginer quand les
ballons de françois ondéron rouge et
jaune au ils sont magnifiques
voilà françois va être content françois
bonsoir oui
qu'y a t'il casimir tu as trouvé quelque
chose à imaginer oui au regard d'arbres
rouge
je vois rien mais je l'aï imaginé avec
des fleurs
tu ne les voit pas elles sont belles
vraiment je vois rien casimir et été
ballon regarde je les ai imaginé avec
des ronds jaunes et rouges mais nous
vraiment casimir je t'aime je vois rien
tu sais kazim et l'imagination peut
créer beaucoup de choses pour soi même
mais les autres ne voient rien personne
d'autre que toi nous voit des fleurs sur
l'arbre rouge et des poids sur mes
balles aux personnes sauf si les imagine
cup
bonjour jean marc qu'est ce que tu veux
oui lequel tend peu un rouge un verre un
jaune
le wallon blain pour journée
[Musique]
hu